it's now two years since El Salvador
became the first country in the world to
introduce Bitcoin as legal tender along
with its regular currency the dollar
so has the experiment succeeded the
general verdict not yet at least
one of the big selling points of the
plan was that Salvadorans would be able
to receive remittances from relatives in
the U.S through Bitcoin using a digital
Chiva wallet
but according to stats from El
Salvador's Central Bank most have chosen
not to
less than two percent of remittances
went through cryptocurrency and digital
wallets so far this year
then there's Bitcoin City a plan
Paradise for Bitcoin enthusiasts powered
by geothermal energy with low taxes and
crypto mining facilities
it was presented by the president at a
bombastic event in November 2021.
because this is a fully fully ecological
City that's works and it's energized by
a volcano
but so far critics say that building has
yet to begun this first bond is the same
ceremony the strategist behind El
Salvador's cryptocurrency adoption
announced the forthcoming creation of
Bitcoin bonds the first one is going to
be a billion dollar Bond and what makes
it a Bitcoin bond is because it's backed
by Bitcoin so half of the billion
dollars will go into buying Bitcoin the
other half will go towards
infrastructure uh specifically building
energy infrastructure and Bitcoin mining
but this so-called volcano bonds have
also yet materialized
meanwhile president bukeli has been
using government funds himself to buy
Bitcoins for the nation announcing on
Twitter when and how much he's purchased
economists have been using those tweets
to work out how those trades have gone
at the price of Bitcoin right now we're
looking at a theoretical loss of 45.4
million dollars of public funds in these
operations and those are just estimates
based on the president's tweets because
there is no information publicly
available about how much he's traded but
while information might be hard to come
by in El Salvador's Bitcoin experiment
one thing is for sure its president
isn't giving up yet John Holman Al
Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera